how's gone brass nice oh yes
ah you're feeling this make me want to
dance
oh oh
this video is being streamed live in
front of a live twitch for live to which
a live twitch audience and since and
your brothers will be able to vote
alright while we play this for stuff to
happen I never played the game before so
I don't even know what I'm gonna do but
we're gonna try it and hopefully I'll be
fine let's start with barbecue party
well we got some nice titties going
party hard Wow okay so here we go do you
see me down here in the left corner you
see this [ __ ] all right this guy's
clearly by himself did I [ __ ] him up
always asleep so I can pick up his body
hey man just got my friend over here
I've got enemy to stab him god kappa
alright arrows you can vote i forgot to
tell you
so oh god know that i use telling the
cops got a kill what an [ __ ] okay so
you bros can vote for pest control pizza
or razor you basically do hashtag one
hashtag two or hashtag three i'm not
sure if that resets the boats yes it
does great alright
hashtag one for swat hashtag two for
bodybuilder hashtag three for carnival
that's right let's go and say hi to
pit-a-pat look at me look at that
[ __ ] just sitting there while
everyone else is partying hahaha ah [ __ ]
clown guy came in and blew my cover the
[ __ ] are you doing clown guy [ __ ]
alright how do I kill there we go
they're both dead I kill Petipa who
called the cops
how do these oh there's a window there
oh man killing pity pie is harder than I
thought
god damn it guys this is not Christian
and I don't appreciate it I'm Christian
come on give me some love no okay
something's gonna happen now the SWAT
team is coming
goddamn it I'm getting swatted on the
stream goddamn it now god damn it how
did you bros find my address [ __ ] yes
look how hard I'm partying whoa yes okay
we're doing well 14 can we do this press
what are you waiting for
everyone wants Go Go Thank You Bret
thank you I'm just gonna chill until we
get the go-go girls
I'm sure the go-go girls will help me
because I need you bros help to kill
people it's kind of romantic in a way oh
there they are
sup ladies whoa
now it's a party what do they do though
how everyone gets attracted to them now
we can kill all the drunken people and
pitter-pat yay let's kill you I don't
like you let's just put this here no one
remembers a thing no one no one
pewdiepie it still doesn't give a single
[ __ ] or God the police coming
please coming please coming please
coming I can't I can't I cannot I can
yeah [ __ ] what you gonna do
[ __ ]
yeah that Super Mario Super a [ __ ]
Mario what are you doing I will crash
you
how did Super Mario get in here how what
is going on oh my god why did they keep
calling the cops
[ __ ] no [ __ ] it's fun he is go go go
god no how no no no I didn't notice I
didn't notice it doesn't count if I
don't notice stop stop no run run run
you [ __ ] whoa run [ __ ] me stupid
stupid second pickup sleeping bodies and
maybe finish them off in another room
that sounds wrong don't do that don't do
that what the [ __ ] did you brush summon
what the [ __ ] is this
did you bros summon a [ __ ] bear with
sunglasses and tie that's awesome
go bear go bear it's like I going into
bed this is gonna do it in the bed Hey
Baby how you doing oh god they're [ __ ]
over here what is special agents doing
why did they kick me no no no you know
what
yeah yeah yeah okay ah yeah
yeah no that's fine hi friends hope you
enjoyed this video if you did go ahead
and check out the game leave it like
bros know what to do sales can I take
these hey Chan